we don't really associate Tom Cruise
with franchises or sequels and yet
exciting news reaches is it true there's
gonna be a Top Gun - I know no oh come
on come on this with this vision was on
the the Tweedy Jerry here we go look
there we go there's dregg brookheimer
sit discuss a little Top Gun yes we're
discussing it
we're discussing it what we're trying
for you now oh do it you're the only
thing I would say is it because again it
goes back to what so I've heard you in
interviews talking about the trials of
being in one of those Jets yeah I mean
it's horrific
or would you be better now because I fly
aerobatic now but when you first start
flying you're gonna you get sick you
know you but I can hopefully see ya
properly like fill a bag sick you know I
know the first day when uh with you you
know you phone him yeah yeah you get
really sick yeah you know I flew with
the Blue Angels and then I went when we
were filming I can my deal was when I
made my deal I said I've got to fly in
the f-14 I made it with the studio and I
had to be filmed in the f-14 live and so
I had to go through all the ejector seat
training and I couldn't wait to fly so
in the morning as their first pilot that
I flew with his name was bozo yeah gives
you confidence yeah don't worry bozo
bozo
and we were up there we had five minutes
of film and we had to turn you know we
had to coordinate he and I and we had
other airplanes coming in on us and
there was air combat maneuvers and we
very detailed briefings and everything
so we're going out and we're just right
you know I don't know couple feet off
the deck in the desert and we're just
sweating I'm sweating in the f-14 and
because we were doing heavy maneuvers
and we did a really heavy maneuver we
pulled like nine and a half G's and I
you know you go out you got a G suit on
but you know you just kind of black out
now when I came through it's like I had
my my barf bag right here my side of
thing I was like okay so now I'm gonna
go get it done so I could do the next
take so I leaned down like this pulled
it I was like just went down like this
and he at that point decided to pull up
he pulled up so hard and for so long I
mean I can't do it now my head literally
was touching to the ground
g-force it Express fine and that pushes
the togs right here is going like this
is like you know I mean he was going up
forever so finally he leveled off and I
just I had the bag man and I was like I
suppose him what didn't you see I like
you get a check you didn't tell me
you're gonna do that my head was like
would it he says yeah yeah they don't
call me bozo for nothing
[Applause]
[Music]